g is an exponential function with an
initial value of negative two so an
initial value of negative two and a
common ratio of one-seventh
common ratio of one-seventh write the
formula for g of t
well the fact that it's an exponential
function we know that its formula is
going to be of the form
g of t
is equal to
our initial value which we could call a
times our common ratio which we could
call r
to the t power it's going to have that
form and they tell us what the initial
value is it's negative 2.
so
this right over here is negative 2 and
we know that the common ratio is 1 7.
so this is 1 7. so let me just write it
again a little bit neater
g of t
is going to be equal to our initial
value
negative 2
times
our common ratio
1 7
to the
t power
and hopefully this makes sense initial
value is this number well if t is equal
to 0 then 1 7 to the 0th power is 1. and
so g of 0 you can view that at time is
being equal to 0 if you view t as time
would be equal to negative 2. so that
would be our initial value and then if
you think about every time you increase
t by one you're going to you're going to
multiply by 1 7 again and so the ratio
between successive terms is going to be
1 7 and so that's why we call that the
common ratio
hopefully you found that interesting